hello folks
welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
science and physics real physics
so if you're not into physics
well um
stick around you might learn something
okay
and what we also talk about here is
extinction we're saying that we are the
last generation of humans on earth
and we look at subjects related to
that topic okay
and so especially some of the headlines
that are out there these days
some of the weird things we see in the
world today also here's a weird thing
fella jumped the gun apparently uh in
norway he started he thought it was the
end of the world probably and started
shooting at people hunting people with
his bow and arrow
says detention here for norway bow and
arrow attacker the guy went out on the
streets with a bow and arrow i mean it's
it's if it weren't so tragic
it's just comical that someone goes out
can you imagine someone going out there
with a bow and arrow hunting people
unbelievable
and uh yeah we're seeing very weird
things today is is this
normal a guy says well i can't buy a gun
and they'll trace it or whatever so i'll
buy a bow and arrow
you know you got all these weird people
out there
okay related to the vaccine
people criticize me and say whoa bill
you got the shot yeah i got the shot
because
i'm going to be traveling and so or i
hope to be traveling and uh
and one of the problems is that you know
the governments everywhere are putting
all kinds of restrictions to those
people who don't get
vaccinated so it's a big problem it's a
big headache so all we can do is uh
you know
either you fight city hall and
do not get
vaccinated and just fight it all the way
or you just
bow down and say okay give me that facts
once and for all and get it over with
you know and that's my attitude i
haven't i don't think i have much to
lose either way
and here you can see how they're
imposing this stuff on everyone says u.s
navy sailors will who refuse
vaccine will be expelled
the united states is going to cut down
on i think like 40 000 some people that
in the navy that are not willing to get
the shots or they expect people not to
get the shots they say they will
convince some of them you know
but others will insist on their religion
on their right to their
opinion or whatever and
they won't get the shot
and they'll be out of uh commission you
know
so yeah i don't know either you fight
city hall or you just
accept it and say well you know
we can't avoid the shots from now it's
gonna they're gonna make it ever more
difficult on people
uh
to stay without you know the vaccine
and so it's up to you if you've got no
no big issues out there yeah you can
skip and say i'm not gonna get the back
seat but if you got to go to work if you
got to travel if you got to do stuff out
there you're going to be a lot of
trouble
they're going to make life very
difficult for you if you don't get the
shot okay and here you see a couple uh
headlines us to lift curves for november
8 for vaccinated foreign travelers and
you can see how they're kind of nudging
you into getting the vaccine no matter
what okay
and another article there should
passengers be vaccinated or tested to
fly within the u.s
so yeah especially for travelers it's
going to be a serious problem they're
going to make like quite difficult for
you
and yeah you can say i'm not going to
get the the backs right okay i you won
that one they'll win all the others
so i don't know i can't tell you all i
can tell you is you know for me it's not
a big issue either way
uh
i don't know too much about vaccines
either way i don't care about them never
it's the subject it doesn't interest me
at all
but you know
i decided that it's better to fall in
line and get the vaccine and not go
through the hassle of all this stuff
other than that i don't care about the
vaccine
someone here i think said um
sad to see the side effects of your
recent experimental treatment are
already setting in yeah i think i got a
little bit sick uh with this especially
the second shot that i got and uh what
what it is is that uh
you know as far as i'm concerned
i'm sneezing
and i got a little bit of sore throat
both mild
mild and but a little bit of runny nose
also all all of them very mild
but you know i think it's related to the
covey because uh shot because you know i
when i get a cold it's serious you know
i i go to bed like for a week at least
and uh and here nothing happened it's
just that a little bit of
cold like i'm very very mild cold but
yeah i felt the difference so
uh i think
the vaccine did something to me it you
know maybe my body's reacting to to
whatever they put in there whatever
poison they put in there
and uh but they say there are some um
some reactions from the body especially
when you get the second one and i think
that's what it was but yeah again i i
don't care but as long as it doesn't
kill me i think i'll i'll be okay
uh dude am i protected against the covet
i have no idea
i i you know it's it's it's just opinion
as far as i'm concerned uh from people
who are not into that subject matter
right now i do understand the the
theory
you know that i understand it now
whether that translates into reality
well that's another thing you know
and right now um
the jury's out in my mind they're still
working out there inside the courtroom
okay
relating to women one fellow says there
is a book called the art of war for
women there you see it okay forget
everything you think you know about
strength strategy and success shows
women how to use sun
tzu's philosophy to win every aspect of
life sun tzu was um
he was a chinese guy who wrote the art
of war but he wrote it for men you know
how to fight into battles out there and
someone uh used as a
art of war for women and fellow says
shows women how to use uh sun says
philosophy okay modern women are
interested in equality uh-huh
when they already rule over men with
covert
heinous backstabbing and feminine
seduction whoa okay that's a good theory
there isn't much of a drive to catch up
to men physically they are better at
dominating in feminine ways uh
there's a famous saying that behind
every successful man there is
a woman
okay so uh
yeah to some degree i i think that's
true you know
you have a wife and your girlfriend
usually wife right uh she nudges you to
do things
it's part of living uh
you know
learning to
cohabit within a house you know you have
to kind of
respect her she's got to respect you and
uh she says why don't you do this why
don't you that she's your counselor you
know and it works in the other direction
as well especially in this these days
you know uh men also uh
give recommendations to women to to
their spouses
uh but yeah i i think you could say that
women don't need the art of war or
really matching man and strength of
power because they have other
tools other weapons
okay that's okay good theory
fella says i'm friends with some
world-class female wrestlers and they
can't compete with the men
yeah nobody said they can compete with
the men um what you have really is um
like you know if you have uh unisex
categories for fighting we're talking
about fighting really tough sports out
there right and you have professional
women and you have professional men
and let's make it unisex now they all
fight against each other within their
weight category
if they want to give some advantage to
the women you know uh saying okay we're
going to let a
little heavier woman
in other words women will be able to at
least at the beginning have a higher
weight
than women than men so that they can
more or less be a little more equal you
know they can play around with those
things but let's say there's a unisex uh
fighting uh
for for anything for boxing for a kick
boxing for any wrestling whatever
uh right now yeah i think uh pound for
pound man for man uh you know every man
uh not every man but most men will beat
most women i'm sure there's a lot of
women out there
within the same
weight category that are probably
skilled uh better skilled or more
skilled than some of the men and they
would probably beat them so even within
the weight categories i think it would
be all men first and then all women
second i think you would have them you
know interspersed uh women will be up
there uh better than some of the men
and all i'm saying is if you let that go
for i don't know 100 200 years will
women gradually come up to speed and be
up to par with men will there be more
women in the upper ranks in that you
know in that whole ranking and the
answer that i have is i don't know
uh and one of the things that
you know has kept up from kept us from
seeing this is the fact that throughout
the centuries you know mencap women uh
kind of down
and women also chose a lot of the things
that women typically do you know like
the kitchen they were
rearing of kids and so on because that's
what they inherited from their
grandmothers and you know the
forefathers
but now you know uh starting with the
service economy women started coming out
of the house and started to work
and a lot of the work out there does not
require any strength or anything like
that it just requires certain abilities
and if the woman
studies
she can be just as good or even better
than some of the men and what's
happening in the world of boxing and
some of these uh
heavy sports
a lot of these uh women um
you know they go in there because of
money
fame
a lot of them like to you know lift
weights and so on they get into those
kinds of things and yeah they
you know they they get into that field
and they can be very good they can be
very good just
much better some of the men in the same
weight category so yeah right now if we
put them if we rank them
i'm sure or we put them like unisex
right now i'm sure most women will be at
the bottom half and most men will be at
the top half and again i'm saying most
there will be women who beat a lot of
the men but given enough time will that
change in such a way that women move up
the ranks
i would suspect that it would happen uh
whether they will always match or
whether there will be a champion woman
within a category well i don't know i
can't tell you that
again the only thing i think would
interrupt that right now is the
extinction of man
if you give uh
us another hundred years who knows maybe
uh women will
have a champion in a given category
okay another foul says it would be
interesting to see and experience a
matriarchal society but the feminist
movement or whatever that's promoting uh
masculine women that we have right now
is mostly due to politics ergo not
natural
uh yeah okay uh there is uh an important
element of politics there
the reason why women of the of the
current age have an increasing social
standing is not due to their natural
competence
in relative
relative to men but simply because they
are intentionally promoted by powerful
men at the expense of common men for
political reasons
i think a lot of that is promoted by
women not so much by men
you know you heard of now an
uh national organization for women you
know they're promoting a lot of the uh
feminist
politics out there not only men it's a
lot of women that are pushing for their
own rights so don't say that you know
we're giving them anything no they're
coming and taking it
okay so i don't know
again uh
you got to look at these uh movements
and find out who's behind them there
could be men behind them for
political and uh profit reasons
but i think the majority are women just
requiring
requesting or demanding really their
rights you know their equality in many
aspects and some of those equalities are
showing up in these heavy sports in this
fight these fighting sports okay
okay here we have a norwegian gender
equality paradox occurs in norway uh-huh
in one of the most progressive countries
okay yet on average women become even
more womenish in their choices
there non-stem non-dangerous and social
jobs them being science technology i
can't remember what he is math is the m
so they're not into the scientific
traditionally
male dominated fields that's what
they're saying i don't think that's true
or it's not it's it's that's fading i
think a lot of women are coming up even
in those
uh categories they're coming up to speed
lately there are more women now in
college than men
and men are just bumming out i guess a
lot of them are frustrated they're
uh
you know their life is over as they say
and women are taking advantage of saying
you know they're
just going to college and then taking
advantage of their educations over a lot
of men who are you know just getting out
of the field and so that's happening as
well but you know uh
in calhoun's experiments
um
for those of you who are familiar with
them
uh you know the female mice
uh they became more aggressive they
became less
female
and the main point there was they
stopped reproducing
okay that's my biggest point when i talk
about
all these equality all these things
or i talk about the fact that women have
are become more masculine masculinized
and by that i don't really mean that you
know they got testosterone in them i'm
saying primarily
uh they don't want to reproduce anymore
okay and you can't get them to have kids
and so
that's the
big portion that will influence
extinction okay so that's why i focus on
that subject if we don't have kids we
don't have demand we don't have demand
uh the economy falls to pieces human
economy the artificial economy we
created is based
on this
um uh
progression where you have more and more
demand next year
uh to drive companies to sell more and
more goods therefore they hire more
people that's the notion but if you have
fewer and fewer consumers because women
are not producing children are not
producing population well at some point
you know that turns a corner
becomes asymptotic which it is right now
it's moving in that direction and at
some point it either levels out or falls
or and
supposedly goes more or less
uh
constant from then on
and i'm saying that's not going to be
the case you either continue increasing
go constant or fall down to extinction
and i'm saying we're going to go down to
extinction once we level off and and hit
that plateau
at zenith it's going to go down to
extinction
that's my take on that
okay
now fellow says
if i can get here
uh the basic problem with equality again
between the sexes
lots of guys answered on this
is that it buys into the white masculine
standards it claims to be viciously
against
white nationalists and anti-racist
disagree only on the science or history
not whether being primitive is such a
bad thing
yeah i don't know uh you do have people
uh out there especially men right in the
world of men uh they're threatened by
this equality
and
and so they what they do they
move to the extremes they either say oh
we have to stop women from
becoming our equals
and
uh
and they want to limit the rights of
women because they see that as a threat
to their masculinity
and all i can tell you is you can't stop
it
you can't stop it and again calhoun's
experiment shows how the males stop
reproducing with the females and females
became more aggressive you can say they
became more masculine
right you had uh homosexual um
mice
and uh again that was documented
so you know
males mounting males and so you have
this situation that really reflects our
own society today in many ways so i
think calhoun's experiments which have
been essentially censored by the
psychology and psychiatry establishments
i think people should really look more
into
uh his experiments and especially his
conclusions i think they are a microcosm
of what is happening to man
okay a fellow says
yeah it says i don't get why some dudes
are so uh feel so insecure and
emasculated that they get scared of
women defying gender roles and norms by
getting good at fighting
it's what pays well today yeah and what
the hell do they expect it is also
because we live in a comfortable city
service economy yeah
celebrities athletes authors are the new
gods of this new sedentary urban hominid
uh
homie okay urban hominid i guess so of
course even women are seeking glory any
way they can
be it through beauty or traditional male
athletic competitions and hobbies yeah
we're in a leisure society and that's
what service economy is
you don't do the work yourself you hired
it out you need someone to fix your
electricity well you don't do it
yourself you hire someone you need
landscaping so you hire someone and so a
lot of people uh have home office among
other things but what they do is they um
they look at things through the internet
and they they're we're all into
entertainment a great majority of the
economy today is driven by entertainment
whether it's travel or whatever you do
through the internet
what do people go through the internet
for a lot of them go for entertainment
and uh and again it's all
abstract all we're doing is exchanging
money around services does not produce
absolutely anything per se it produces
only when that
money that circulates in the service
economy somehow trickles over to
manufacturing and agriculture or
construction you can say that's part of
manufacturing in the sense that we're
manufacturing a street manufacturing a
bridge or whatever so it's only when it
translates into manufacturing or
agriculture that we have something real
being produced and you could say at that
point now we actually have
uh real growth in the economy as long as
we're sending money around you know
paying a guy to sing
and the other guy to do a program and
the other guy to have you know sex with
a prostitute
none of that
produces anything real any any
growth any real growth
so it and the problem here is that
agriculture and manufacturing not only
have become but are still becoming
smaller and smaller percentages
of the economy what's growing is
services more people are getting in
there and it's more a bigger percentage
of gdp how long can we continue doing
that producing stuff that is not
productive at all
and meaning the real productive stuff
like agriculture and manufacturing
shrink day by day
this is the issue that's why i'm saying
you can't continue that forever and
right now we are continuing it forever
that's the problem
okay uh here's another
comment
says defining sex with only chromosomes
creates a loophole that in fact trans
people use okay irrelevant that was a
good surface definition you gave with
the chromosomes but not quite
sex is more than just chromosomes it's
the whole body mechanism
well you know the way the way i look at
it is that um
you want to know if a guy is a male or a
female i don't care if he had a sex
change operation or she you know it
doesn't really matter you look at their
chromosomes and you'll find out if they
got
you know xx or xy and then you'll know
what what they really are what category
they belong to and what bathroom they
should go to
okay i think uh i i don't know of any
exceptions to that where you know
there's some
guy out there that might or gal
that has a mixture of chromosomes
i don't know uh as far as i'm concerned
you know it's
xy and xx maybe there are some
exceptions but again the few exceptions
would not justify
changing the rule that i'm suggesting
i'm saying we should just determine
uh who's male and who's female by the
chromosomes i don't care what they have
in their brain i don't care if they
think this way or that way i think we
should just leave it to you know the
chromosomes it's objective the other one
is subjective you know the guy says i
think i'm a woman well yeah maybe if you
think you're a woman then that's great
but you know your body says something
else
so
i don't know that's my take on that and
yeah the one the question you should ask
is why are we having so many of these
these days
okay uh suddenly you know they started
all coming out of the closet all these
transsexuals and the question is
is this something genetic
the fact that we've been inbreeding for
200 000 years and now it's catching up
with us especially now that our
population has increased dramatically in
the last 200 years i think it's all
related to that
okay a fellow says
did your wife already catch up to you
and force you to spread feminist
propaganda
yes honey please please don't hit me i i
i'll say whatever you want
yeah
uh
women are tough you know especially when
they have that
what is it there
don't roller
yeah she caught up with me uh she tells
me what to say here and i better say it
because he's got a gun pointed at me
right now so i better
be nice
and say like she wants it said okay
okay another fella says uh urbanization
so i was wondering why it is that people
are leaving the countryside okay
what i learned is that people aren't
moving out of small towns so much as
small towns are getting so over
populated in other words he's saying
it's not that you're in this little
country village
and people are living leaving the
village because there's no work or
whatever and they go to the big city
because they can do a lot better over
there
what's happening is he's
saying according to what he looked at is
that the little villages are becoming
towns and the towns are becoming cities
they're growing and so they're
disappearing as
uh country cities
country towns country villages and
they're becoming metropolitan areas
that's what he's suggesting
um
and what i'm saying is uh
i've got a different take on this he
says now sure how that fits into your
theory but i personally had it backwards
i thought that these towns were drying
up i think both things are happening
okay both things are happening and
either way it's more or less irrelevant
you can see the chart right at the
bottom uh in the last couple hundred
years
urbanization has increased dramatically
people have left the country and come to
the city they've done that partly
because the big corporations have bought
out the farms bought out the
land
and
they they have these uh
economies of scale in which they produce
food for eight billion people and the
little farmer's the guy that's losing
out little by little they're being
kicked out of the farms either because
they can't pay the bank loans or for
totally different reasons
maybe the new generations don't want to
farm anymore whatever and all these
people are moving to the uh towns and
from there to the cities and at the same
time you know you do have the little
towns that are growing and becoming
cities so i think both things are going
on the important thing is what you see
there that urbanization
is the is
the direction in which we're going
and you know i saw uh i showed my
little uh gift there where
you have uh some fruits and you have the
bacteria or the uh whatever the
fungus grow on it
exponentially at first and then at some
point the whole thing collapses and dies
why because you know at some point you
can't continue
reproducing bacteria over anything or
fungus over anything it's a matter of
what the ratio is at some point you know
there's going to be a density dependent
birth rates for that species
and they're going to stop expansion
expanding exponentially they're going to
hit the plateau and come back down
and i think that's what's going to
happen to man in in in the sense that we
moved to the cities the cities are
growing fast yeah we've had growth in
the last few 50 years especially and
then
i'd say even from the 1950s right after
the war right and then what happened uh
at some point you know you can't
continue having
uh millions and millions more millions
of people like in new york city or in
tokyo or the big cities around the world
at some point that's going to stop
okay because you know you just can't fit
physically more people in that little in
that big town okay and that's the issue
uh some players gonna level off
and that's what what i call density
dependent birth rates you know and yeah
if you look at density dependent birth
rates there's been a lot of studying
on that especially for animals
but
of course they
recognize that it applies to men as well
we're part of the
wild kingdom
okay
okay here we have another one uh says
conference of the new world order 2015.
and this is a statement that was pulled
out of there i have not been able to
verify this i had no time to look this
up but a fellow says apparently he's
quoting someone there that the
conference says because the intention of
the
of the
new world order is to reduce the number
of people in this world at the time when
the new world order was initiated the
population of this world was only 3
billion which was around the time when i
was born in the 50s okay
and
the intention was to reduce to 1 billion
now the population of the world is 7
billion yeah okay
and there will be a need to kill many
billions of people or to starve them to
death or to prevent them from
giving birth in order
to reduce the population of this world
so uh the new world order apparently uh
assuming this uh statement is true
um
is that
uh they will reduce the population of
the world they say we're too many
already
and we got a problem with that because
on the one hand yeah that's great for uh
resources and it's great for um
the ratio of resources to man
and
that's on the one hand but on the other
hand we got a problem because you know
our economy is based on
more and more people more demand
and so there's a contradiction between
uh
pollution and all this other stuff
related to high population
and
a contradiction with the business world
that requires more and more people in
order to have more and more demand
and so by let's say let's say uh you
know by an act of god we chop off uh 3
billion or 4 billion of our population
so we got 8 billion people we chop off 4
billion we're left with 4 billion people
are we better off or worse i mean you
might say well
we have less pollution now this this and
that yeah great how about business now
the business suddenly has much less
demand and closes its doors kicks
everybody out of the the
their jobs
and now you kill the economy
so
yeah you need more population and again
it's an inverted pyramid scheme what
you're talking about you need more and
more population for our global economy
to continue thriving
if you stop population growth you're
doing excellent stuff for pollution and
climate change all that stuff
and you're doing terrible stuff for the
economy the economy will shut down and
we're all dead anyways one way or the
other so it's a no-win situation we're
dead one way or the other
okay um
because or someone says have military
strategists consider that both china and
taiwan have operable nuclear power
reactors used for electricity generation
yeah a major conflict could result
in could possibly result in damage to
the water cooling loops causing possible
core meltdown and spent fuel rod storage
pools boiling dry yeah
if there is a nuclear war
forget it if they start throwing the
nukes
we're all dead i don't think we can come
out of a nuclear war exchange because uh
you know it means that all stops are off
you know if someone throws their first
bomb to the other side
it's a free-for-all everybody will just
let go of the bombs before the other guy
destroys the bombs locally
you know and you have submarines out
there and they can shoot
you know their bombs and you can locate
the somebody in submarine maybe throw a
bomb there and blow it up but maybe
through this throws the uh bomb before
you blow it up and it
wipes out a million people in the city
so you know i don't you know i think
that's why nobody's right now
uh really
very happy about trying to push the red
buttons
but if someone pushes the red button
tomorrow because they want to win the
conventional war
or they're losing a conventional war and
they say well i'm just going to throw
the bomb in and liquidate you know the
other guy's army or navy or whatever
we're all in trouble because at that
point everybody will press the buttons
that's the way i see it i don't think
we'll come out of a nuclear exchange
so yeah nobody better touch those red
but those buttons hopefully will never
be touched even though it might happen
at the last moment anyways you know
okay the us does uh have a choice in
whether or not they go to war with
taiwan uh their fear that china is uh
doing better than the u.s has become a
stronger world power is not a good
reason for starting a war with them the
u.s also is jealous of them and it's not
their country so they should stay out of
it taiwan is part of china it's still
not any other country's place to
actually interfere much less start wars
over it
yeah see uh one thing is ideal
people have these ideals about justice
what justice should be
and apparently this person says uh
united says states has no business being
in taiwan
or yeah or
fighting against china by
you know giving weapons to taiwan first
and if china happens to attack
get involved in the fight and defend
taiwan but that's the way politics has
always been i mean you know uh
in argentina we had the uh falkland war
uh did the falkland uh uh island belong
to argentina or to
great britain well the way it's settled
is by going to the field and fighting
that's the way it's settled
otherwise it doesn't get settled
taiwan's gonna be no different you know
they're not gonna resolve that by saying
okay let's sign a treaty and taiwan
becomes a country of its own with its
own rulers china is not going to stand
for that china is going to work its way
all the way to conquering taiwan
remember taiwan came into being only
because you know chiang kai-shek
escaped aft to taiwan after mao
uh beat him in the civil war and so
china became communist because you know
mao im imposed communism uh in china
so-called communism uh dictatorship with
a proletariat
and
the island taiwan is the only one that
escaped that fate because you know
chiang kai-shek
immediately you know
created all these defenses against
mainland china so as one grew the other
one grew as well
and now several generations later these
people saying hey
taiwan is part of china
and the taiwanese are saying come here
and prove it
so uh yeah there's there's a lot of
problems out there and there's a result
by weapons they're not resolved by what
is justice who something belongs to you
know uh what was it
the monroe doctrine said that uh you're
talking about the early 1800s right
when the united states was an enemy
of england of the united kingdom of
great britain and people don't realize
that but throughout the 20 19th century
england and the united states were
enemies today they're friends it's hard
to believe that in those days they were
enemies
and england did everything possible to
destroy the united states to break it up
civil war they took the side of the
south et cetera they wanted to break up
this big
country that was developing out there
and uh the monroe doctrine uh
issued by james monroe you know
he said look uh anything involving the
americas
we're going to
go against europe no matter what you
know america for the americas
essentially that was the monroe doctrine
and
when the [ __ ] war happened uh
argentina and some other countries in
south america says hey remember the
monroe doctrine
uh and the united states said well you
know we we're going to take the side of
of the europeans in this case
and so they
picked they pocketed their uh
the monroe doctrine and used another
doctrine they use whatever they need at
whatever time they need and that's the
same for every country in the world i
mean does israel control
uh the middle east there that country
called israel
uh you've got the west bank right you've
got these
pieces of land that are occupied
by arabs that lost the war in 1967 they
don't care they just take the land how
about the golden heights uh
in syria that's land taken by the united
by israel and israel now saying well
that's our land now
and syria can go fight it out in the
united nations good luck there you know
no they're going to have to fight for it
they're going to have to send an army
there and beat the
settlers the israel army and that's
occupying the land and if they can't do
it that land belongs to whoever can
defend it that's how simple it is it has
nothing to do with justice
justice is
like uh what was it
he said
you look at justice through the barrel
of a gun
and that's the best way to put it
okay changing a little bit of the
subject here we have something about the
neanderthals what is your opinion on the
neanderthal super predators theory parts
of his theory is that neanderthals were
basically nocturnal okay if so this
might explain how homo sapiens
were able to drive the much larger and
physically stronger neanderthals extinct
aha okay this was done by attacking
neanderthal man during the day while
they were asleep
okay it also might explain where one our
tales of werewolves and vampires came
from
okay uh
what can i tell you um this theory of uh
neanderthal super predator comes from
this fellow
his name is danny
bender mini
and he this he says that
neanderthal did not look like what the
establishment puts out there it looks a
little different
it looks like that gorilla that you see
there big etc mean looking
he had an artist
make this uh this
image of neanderthal
okay and uh
i agree with some things with uh mr van
romini uh and so all i can do is show
you what i agree with him and the first
one that i
disagree is
the looks i'm saying it looks more like
that which is the
perhaps one of the first maybe it was
the first
neanderthal that was
imaged and that was in 1909
and
i think that's more or less what the
nether looked like this other one the
one that he points out it looks more
like a monster i don't think any animal
would look
quite like that so in that sense we
agree that this animal this
neanderthal was hairy uh he was living
in the arctic developed in the arctic
okay so
he he wore no clothes as you can see and
i don't think he wore any clothes i
think humans did you know crow magnets
uh we did wear clothes
and i think uh also that
neanderthals were stronger and
better built for
fighting than each individual man
so i think they were much uh formidable
much more formidable in the uh
in in any fighting category okay so i
think they were tough uh groups they
also
worked in clans they worked together
so they had many advantages in that
sense
where do i disagree with him well i
disagree with him in that sense that
he says that
the neanderthals let me get rid of this
it says that the neanderthals um
moved around and uh they went from
europe around the black sea
and into the middle east because they
found some neanderthals in the middle
east
and so vender mini says that well we had
humans come from africa
they met with the neanderthals there in
uh
in the levant especially in uh israel
syria and iraq
and that's where we find some bones
and
humans
killed them
we were superior to the neanderthals
again that's that
they killed them during the day while
the other guys slept at night that's why
we were able to
get rid of the neanderthals now the
neanderthals did not die because humans
got rid of them in any way shape or form
humans had nothing at all to do with the
extinction of the neanderthals we did
not mate with them we never had sex with
them he also mentions that by the way
that the neanderthals were raping our
women
you can imagine that monster uh
sleeping with one of our ladies
i can't i don't think he would uh like a
lion trying to
sleep with one of the wild dogs out
there in africa i don't think a lion
would do that okay but anyways the the
issue is that um i don't think that
neanderthals went around the black sea
to the south to warm climates such as
israel
lebant
neanderthals never had a reason to leave
europe because it was sufficient there
was more than enough game
first of all their populations were
relatively small
and because humans
went up north to europe
and why did they go there i think they
followed the herds i think humans were
looking for game game was probably
scarcer in the south in
africa and so on
the the
animals were somehow apparently going
north or maybe the humans were just
drifting
northwards as they look for game and
they eventually ended up in europe
and the only reason that humans were
able to finally enter europe is because
the neanderthals were gone
the neanderthals
were imploding the population of
neanderthals were imploding apparently
they ended up
i think either in what is known as
yugoslavia that region there
or spain that's i think one of those two
places maybe they made their last stand
maybe it was italy but that's where they
probably made their last stand more than
likely it was over there in gibraltar
but
they imploded their population imploded
humans had nothing to do with it
the only reason humans entered europe is
because the neanderthals were dying were
disappearing and now humans were able to
walk in there
that's that's my take on that so uh
vendor mini's notion that this was
because humans killed them or that
the neanderthal had sex with our women
uh and the other one that neanderthals
were in the levant uh there's a couple
studies out there i mentioned them in
the past and that's that the
neanderthals in the levant are not
even similar no i can't see not at all
but they're not there are many
differences between the so-called
neanderthals in the levant
and the neanderthals in the west like in
france
uh
spain and
germany
there's differences
you know noticeable differences so i
don't think what they found in the
middle east are neanderthals okay there
was some other hominin that was living
there
we were still evolving uh whether those
are our ancestors or somehow they died
out and humans later came out
that's uh you know we don't have enough
samples out there to be able to decide
that
in any way shape or form i can only make
assumptions and my assumptions is that
the
hominins that we find in the middle east
were not either humans or
neanderthals there were some other
species like you have the denisovans in
russia and so on i think these were
different species just scattered
throughout the planet
okay and uh yeah and here is the
where we agree with mr vendramini and
that's uh
you know uh
what they've done the establishment they
made
neanderthals ever more human-like over
this century you can see from 1909 to
2015 how neanderthal has uh modified uh
his aspect he's become more more like us
okay so much so that in the neanderthal
museum
they put some clothes on him
you know the guys got suit and tie
and like saying you know if you see a
nandeth out there you would not
recognize him i think you would i think
he looks more like that guy
on the left-hand side
okay and uh final issue here uh
same person i think says here's a video
which calls into question the out of
africa theory okay there are multiple
other pieces of evidence that call this
theory into question including early
hominins existing in south america okay
thousands of years ago
fossil discoveries in china which place
early man there much earlier than he
should have been and evidence that proto
man emerged from australia 50 000 years
ago it interbred with another form of
hominin ham in it uh to produce what
they what we know as homo sapiens
okay all i can tell you is um
that my theory has to do with the
overturning of the population pyramid
that's how the neanderthals died
and i think
humans did originate in africa primarily
because we don't find homo habilis
anywhere other than in africa at least
so far the day we find a homo habilis in
china or in indonesia or whatever then
maybe we can change our
perspective but right now you know and i
put that in my book how the neanderthals
disappeared
i talk about the chinese
in there i also talked about homo
erectus uh who was
also all the way up to
china and uh indonesia
and what i'm saying is those guys did
not originate in china or in australia
or in indonesia now i think uh
the out of africa theory is correct and
that's the assumption i make for all
this i'm saying that we came out of
africa and homo erectus did and
he's the guy the ancestor of
neanderthals and also of some of the
uh
hominins that we see in the east but i
think what happened essentially is that
um after homo erectus
went east their population somehow
disappeared and new waves of humans
coming out of africa repopulated china
and australia and so
that's my take on that there's we as of
today we have relatively little evidence
there are very few skeletons found uh in
china and again they're still looking
for
for stuff maybe we had a head start in
the west we found a lot of skeletons
especially in europe and i don't see i
don't think you'll we have yet found
enough
bones in china to be able to make any uh
conclusive
or or come up with conclusive theories
something more
uh that can be sold out there right now
i think
what we find in in china is that uh they
were repopulated by humans coming from
africa and that's that's my take until i
see something different those are the
assumptions i make so yeah this is my
take here the overturning of the
population uh pyramid and i'm saying
that neanderthals died when their
population pyramid overturned and what
are we saying there uh one study okay
and there you see the study says adult
longevity increased with human evolution
from a ratio of old to young adults of
about 0.12 to 0.4 for neanderthal
fossils with a particularly dramatic
increase in paleolithic societies to
more than two older adults for each
younger adult
what had changed over
the years
from maybe three hundred thousand four
hundred thousand years ago to when the
neanderthals disappeared around forty
thousand years ago the upper paleolithic
what changed with the ratio of old to
young people their population pyramid
overturned and if you look it up and do
some
research out there you can look up a
couple of my videos on the neanderthal
series where i talk about it and i
mention the
the papers the references
their genetic diversity also decreased
from about 80 000 years ago to when they
disappeared 40 000 years ago in those 40
000 years you can see that there is a
loss of genetic diversity among the
neanderthals they were able to measure
that
whether you want to believe in that or
not
it does fit my theory quite well so both
of these the fact that they lost their
genetic diversity and the fact that they
became older as time went by gives me a
clue that their population pyramid
overturned because they had been around
for
too long
okay so
let's do the physics part today
and i'm going to start with a little
recap
here it is
um
what do we covered so far on this
subject that we started about a couple
weeks ago uh
first thing is that
mathematics does not have distance they
have no idea what distance is they don't
use the distance of physics which is
separation okay now they use the
distance traveled they unroll the end of
their measuring tape every time they
talk about distance
so because a mathematician cannot use
cannot put in an equation separation
that's a qualitative concept they have
no place to put it in an equation makes
no sense now they have to put a number
and what number are they going to put
followed by a unit
they got to put meters per second what
is is meters per second uh a distance
no it's a distance traveled or they put
meters and you say well what do you mean
meters well it's the amount of meters
that the end of the rolling the tape uh
unrolled to which is again meters
traveled
maybe it's not meters per second but it
is the quantity of meters
okay
and uh
so
distance traveled is not equal the
distance distance is what we have in
physics separation that's qualitative
has nothing to do with the notion of
math which is distance traveled which
again is how many meters how many meters
did you unroll the tip of your measuring
tape okay
and so yeah uh distance in math is total
amount an object has traveled in a
period of time
okay and uh synonym is length see they
measure length in the same way
uh in other words you want to know how
long the table is you what you do you
unroll first you create a standard the
meter for example the foot whatever and
then you unroll the measuring tape and
you say okay i got five meters
from here from the beginning of the
table to the end of the table
so are you talking about some kind of
separation are you talking about
distance now you're talking about
distance traveled in every case whether
you measure length or distance or even
uh position as i've got there distance
traveled is equal to position and equal
to displacement equal to length these
are synonyms there's no difference
between them whatsoever okay and people
say what are you saying bill yeah i'm
saying that exactly let me show you why
his position okay you say position
is a static concept right here i am i'm
at this position right
no in not in math okay they can't use
the word position for anything so what
they did they turned it into a dynamic
concept okay here it is okay this is
position you got the treasure map you
got the treasure over there upper right
hand corner okay and what you're staring
at is not
position of the treasure chest what
you're staring at is the um
spec
the
recipe the
the way to get
to the uh treasure chest you're talking
about instructions on how to get there
and what you have to do is you walk 34
paces to the right and 15 to the north
and you arrive at your treasure chest
that's the position that they use in
mathematics so they're talking about two
itineraries okay
and or you can go like the ship there
you know you can dock in them from their
walk all the way to the uh to the
treasure chest each one of those red
dots uh that's a position what is a
position how to get there
so there is no such thing as position
the qual qualitative concept in
mathematics they have no use for that
what they have is um
uh
motion
mathematic
mathematics i call it right all they do
is have motion
uh mathematics only uh has used for
motion has no use for any static concept
so yeah all those are synonyms because
they all involve motion little things
that concern mathematicians they say
well this distance is different than
position which is different than
displacement
uh petty stuff that only concerns
mathematics it has no bearing whatsoever
in physics okay and so all these are
dynamic concepts in
mathematics because otherwise they
couldn't use it in any equation okay
and velocity well again we have here the
situation where velocity a single value
in space and in time that's what
velocity is okay
uh what is velocity a motion in one
frame of the film
so how can you have motion in a single
frame of the film
it's like if you take a cross-section of
time and that's
velocity at that cross-section of time
which has no width whatsoever because
you're talking again about concept you
can't chop concepts but that's
essentially what they do they have the
timeline the number line
in seconds minutes hours whatever they
want
they cut through it they slice through
it as soon as you want using god's sword
right and once you get to that point you
say well that's the velocity here but
see if if you had no direction all you
would have is speed the way you turn it
into velocity is by putting smiley there
you have to show that that single point
has direction so so you have to put a
face on smiley because we have to know
which way he's pointing with his face
okay so
velocity is that combination of speed
plus direction but direction is a
qualitative concept and they have no use
in
mathematics for qualitative concept they
can't put it in the equation they can't
do anything with
okay so that's the recap
and some one fellow out there says
i'm lost on this video what exactly is
bill arguing for or against i need
velocity uh i used velocity in high
school physics when uh there was a ball
on a slope with a gravity pulling it
down
yeah gravity pulls it down right
whatever gravity is gravity is a
physical object that pulls
uh
think about your wording because people
use that wording and then when you say
well if it's pulling what's pulling on
you say well that's just a figure of
speech no no don't use it if you're
gonna say pull why didn't you say push
why don't you say gravity is push
gravity like some people out there say
right and if it's pushing what does that
pushing in
thing look like okay but
that's on the margin here i wasn't being
taught velocity in high school math okay
you have a direction if there's gravity
or the object has eyes
yeah
for a single point you have to have eyes
you have to show the crowd what
direction
that
ball is moving towards but let's go here
in
a little more detail okay
here's a velocity of the object okay why
does it have velocity well because it's
got a smiley face on it okay well he's
not smiling very much but imagine that
okay so you can see that he's going
towards the uh what is in your case uh
to the right okay he's moving to the
right why is he moving to the right well
he because his face is pointed to the
right okay so that's the direction in
which that ball is moving
and if you have the value of the
magnitude of the uh
of the speed right plus the direction
well now you have velocity okay but you
have a single point a cross section of
time don't lose track of that because
velocity is a cross-section of time it's
just a single point in time
uh
gazillions of decimal points
in time okay so it's
uh
second number five with gazillions of
decimal points
okay so that's what uh velocity is
and uh so you have to have a smiley face
for direction because if you remove the
smiley face okay let's remove the smiley
face okay uh now that object uh becomes
more plainly plain to see okay here it
is dot the object okay
now you remove the uh
the direction you don't know what
direction that dot is pointing now you
have if anything is speed okay and again
like i pointed out the other day is
unless you have a second point inside
that frame
of the movie okay
unless you have a second point you don't
know in which direction that's going
first but you don't know the speed
either because you need a reference
to calculate speed
especially you know average speed okay
so
this is where the problem starts
what you've done is essentially without
a reference you have no direction no
speed all you have is the object you
have the little ball that is a point in
time and point in space
that's all you have in front of you
objectively okay and if you remove that
you have absolutely nothing you have
space
so you have to put something in there if
you're going to talk about something and
there you have a something what you have
is a dot
that's the object called dot
does that dot have speed and direction
no absolutely not and this is the
problem they what they've done is by
taking the limit
right as x equals zero right what
they've done is uh
convert a concept called speed
into a dot
into an object into a thing
that's what they've done the
mathematicians don't care about objects
they just care about their calculations
so uh they were at home with that they
said no problem we just calculate that
value yeah but what you've done from a
physical point of view is to by going
you know taking the limit of whatever
your limit you take out there what
you've done is zero in on an object on
the object itself
and the object here is
supposedly location but what is location
without an object absolutely nothing so
you need the object to establish the
location when it which in this case is
actually positioned because for location
you also need distance
okay so that in a nutshell is summary
there and here we have it okay
velocity what is it uh well first of all
speed is equal to meters per second in
other words that's what you measure it
in those are the units you can have
other units as well but meters per
second is the official
version there velocity is the same thing
meters per second because that's what
they're going to put in the equation are
they going to put direction in the
equation
no they can't put
so they never talk about velocity
essentially they talk about speed they
talk about the speed of light and they
put
you know uh
300 000 kilometers per second
is there anything there that gives you
an idea of direction when you say 300
000 kilometers per second where's the
direction
they can't put direction so they never
talk about the velocity of light they
talk about the speed of light because
again
they don't need to find out what the
speed is at a given point across section
of time
they don't need the speed of light at
that point
they just said the speed of light in
general you know 300 000 kilometers per
second they put the little c in there
right which is represents that value
and math has no use for qualitative
concepts you can place a qualitative
concept you can't uh place a qualitative
concept in an equation or perform
mathematical operations
on qualitative concepts such as
direction
so direction is something that the uh
mathematicians incorporated
together with speed to create this
concept known as velocity they needed it
for angular momentum okay when a planet
moves around they said well
if it's in a straight line no problem in
speed no problem we don't have any
problem there but when it turns the
corner now what do we call it well they
had to invent this notion of speed and
the only difference between speed and
velocity was the direction
okay
because as long as they're on the same
line displacement uh speed uh position
it's all the same
okay
and so you know they have
they can use all these dynamic cons and
just assign different names to them
because they have minor differences
between them that don't concern physics
at all okay and they can't put the
qualitative
notion of each one of these in an
equation
all they can do is put the value that
they need for whatever calculation they
have to
do okay
again uh what is velocity a single frame
in the universal movie make that frame
as thin as you want as small as you want
because it's a single frame in god's
movie okay so
uh can you have uh direction in in a
single frame can you have even speed in
a single frame no you can't but
mathematicians manage to do it through
again you know taking derivatives and so
on
okay
give me a second here
here we have
continuing with this here we have the
conclusion i guess
of this
what what are the differences between
math and physics well in math you have
distance travel and displacement
they could be the same if it's on the
straight line only but if distance
traveled is curved then uh we have
different values and different notions
they say well this one's displacement
and that one's distance traveled uh the
distance you traveled from s1 to s2 is
on a curve okay so that's a value that's
different from displacement which is
just a difference in
in locations of these two uh points
and so
you know in physics we have we call it
something different we say the top one
the blue one is called motion
and we usually represent it with dashed
or dotted lines to show that it's
segmented that it's a bunch of locations
and you know you can fit as many
locations as you want in there the
object only can have one location so
it's a discrete location no matter what
when it moves to another location it's
discrete again because the previous
location disappeared right now we have
that concept that continuously
disappears in the back and
recreates itself in the front
so we call that was how we use a dotted
line
to represent motion and we don't call it
distance travel we call it motion that's
all it is okay and displacement if it's
just a separation between s1 and s2 we
call it distance all we're talking about
is the separation between those two
points
and so uh you can see that what is
qualitative the other one is used for
calculations
and so i like to summarize that and say
distance is what is between lengths why
because distance is not the same thing
as length in uh physics
uh there are two different concepts all
together length is what is
within an object from one face to the
other that's what we call length that's
separation
and this is what is between two objects
uh and that's not the case in
mathematics for them it's all the same
thing distance travel displacement uh
length it's all the same because all
they're doing is stretching the
measuring tape from one end to the other
they don't care what they measure
what they're actually measuring is the
measuring tape itself you know when when
the astronaut goes to space
right
and he stretches his
uh
measuring tape across space
what he's measuring is this measuring
tape not space okay and that's the issue
but in math you can get away with that
because you don't deal with objects
you're dealing with abstractions
okay and so here let's move on to time
and
how do we come to the subject of time
well we come through the subject of time
because remember speed is equal to this
um
distance divided by time and now what
we're going to do is put time on the
other side and speed on this side right
we're going to exchange them there and
we're going to find out what the
definition or the notion of time is
and there's a difference again here
between
mathematics
and science between
mathematical physics and
physics proper genuine physics okay so
let's start here we start we're at
aristotle because see aristotle um he
was one of the first guys in fact i
think it's the first president that we
have i don't know about the east maybe
some chinese guy did the same thing i
have no idea or an arab or whatever but
as far as i'm concerned uh aristotle was
the first one to analyze time in quite a
bit of detail okay and so i'm not going
to give you this whole
notion let me get it here
i'm just going to show you here
uh how he went about thinking about time
okay and and what we inherited from him
and so he started his reasoning here he
says physics book four okay he says time
does it belong to the class of things
that exist or to that of things that do
not exist
so he wanted to know or he wanted to get
to the bottom of whether time exists or
not that was one of the issues
and in the other issue he says was its
nature
i mean what is time okay so he wanted to
understand that okay that's where we
start and let's see where he went with
this well he he did
this analysis essentially i just took
bits and pieces to give you the the main
points okay so you don't have to read
them all over again but you can it's in
book four again and he says time is
present
equally everywhere and with all things
okay so he said everything is affected
by time
time is continuous by which he meant not
that it's
what we call continuous made of a single
piece no for him continuous means it's
divisible that's what it means exactly
the opposite that's what continuous
meant to
i guess not only aristotle but to the
greeks in general
time is neither fast nor slow but many
are few long or short okay time does not
exist without change or movement
but if we have change or movement i
guess then you can say time exists
according to aristotle okay so we have
something here saying time does exist
uh the only condition is that it have uh
change or movement
time is a measure of motion okay some
kind of measure of motion time is not
movement itself but movement insofar as
it admits of enumeration
time is what is counted
okay so time refers to the number that
you use to
describe or count movement or change
time is
number of movement in respect to
uh of the before and after
okay so these are the starting points of
humanity i guess you could say
uh our notion of time it had to do with
uh mr aristotle doing an analysis
and he's saying essentially that
number is not time but what you
enumerate is time what are you
enumerating amount of motion
okay
so he said what is time essentially it's
motion it's numbers applied to motion
okay that was his
overall uh notion
we're going to short circuit uh all the
guys in between because they didn't add
really very much to the word time until
we get to the 17th century okay 17th
century you can call it the century of
time for several reasons
first um well we had the scientific
revolution that's what a 17th century is
typically known for okay
invention of the calculus we had these
two gentlemen uh mr leibniz and newton
uh they're fighting over who invented
the calculus but they both apparently
uh developed it he uh invented it we use
leibniz notation today we do not use
newtons at all okay
and also
what discovered in those days or what
was invented what was proposed is the
wave nature of light by mr hook okay he
was the first one to
talk about the wave nature it was later
developed by huggins okay dutch fellow
and uh
both huggins and
hook they also work with clocks
this was a time where you know people
were talking about clocks and time and
time started uh becoming a more
important issue among the theorists and
one of the first ones was
galileo
galileo galilei and what galileo did was
he tried to measure the speed of light
and
very awkward i showed that in the past
where you know he had his
assistant in one mountain he was in
another mountain and they had their
latin lanterns covered and they said
look when when i uncover
my lantern i want you to uncover it
immediately as you see the light uncover
yours so that i can see your light and
they kept doing this you know like
uncover the other guy uncovered and they
said
light is faster than we can uncover and
so he concluded that light was
instantaneous there was no speed to
light and that would change with mr
romer who
a danish guy who eventually
showed that because of one of the moons
of jupiter
the light coming from
when the moon was behind jupiter and
when it was in front of jupiter as it
rolled around they said well what's the
difference uh that moon should have come
out earlier
and
the reason it came out later he said is
the speed of light it takes light
time
to get from
that moon to our eyes when it's you know
on the other side of jupiter
and especially you know when there was a
difference in uh like six months
difference where jupiter was on the
other side of the earth you know the
earth that was now here it was close to
jupiter here it was farther away and now
why was there a difference well the
speed of light okay and that's what
romer discovered so uh you know they
were looking at the relationship between
time and the speed of light
and you know a couple uh
decades later you have uh
what was it uh james bradley he uh
also used parallax to determine the
speed of light calculated value always
and until you get to the 19th century
you know uh people like pro cult
and fizzo they started measuring light
again always round trip okay in their
case and what they did in most of these
cases is calculate angles okay so
this is essentially
where we are today we don't have a
one-way speed of light as far as i know
there's been no experiment on one-way
speed of light they should do one
because i think we have the capability
and the way we would do it is by sending
someone to the moon
and it takes light two sec
one second and not quite two seconds
it's a little over a light second for
light to reach from a laser here on
earth all the way to the moon and so we
would have a one-way
mechanism that someone maybe an
astronaut could uh
measure somehow
by receiving light one way okay
and so
but again uh the problem there would be
communication you know it's more or less
like
galileo's lantern you know the guy here
says okay i sent the laser the other guy
said okay i received it
uh yeah the the sound would also take a
speed of light to get to the moon
so i don't know maybe there is a way of
doing it uh someone smarter than me can
figure it out but i don't think it's
important at all
light in physics we say light is fast
is that accurate enough okay it's very
fast that's a little more accurate
that's all we need light is fast now we
got to figure out what light is
and likewise we have to figure out what
time is is time something physical
is times something related to math to
physics at all do we need time in
physics
or is it just a calculation that they
need in mathematics which is unrelated
to physics entirely okay so this is the
question
okay so um
here we get to mr newton and he more or
less synthesizes the notion that people
had in the 17th century about
time what is time and here uh newton's
going to give us the scientific
uh super duper definition of time okay
here it is it says i do not define time
space place and motion as being well
known to all
yeah he
all these people work with
force which involves time acceleration
which involves time speed velocity
involves time all that involves time no
one knew no one could define the word
time because as he says but we all know
what time is and just in case they
didn't define motion or space because we
all know what that is as well so we
don't have to define any of those things
you just go with your intuition and say
okay i know what motion is i know what
space is i know what
time is
and then you have today 21st century and
the mathematicians are saying space is
made of particles
so it's a little different than what
newton probably thought of space and
means that no newton you did not know
what space is no one knew what space is
because now they're saying space is a
physical object it's a block of stone
made of particles that come in from the
void and separated into positive and
negative
so do we know what space is well we
don't know what space is i guess we
don't know
what uh time is either so what do we
know i mean the mathematicians right
and do we need this at all do we need
time at all what is time do we need it
do we use it in physics
and math obviously they use something
called time do we need it in physics
okay so let's continue to find out what
this time thing is here we again uh
short circuit to the 20
20th century uh and we have mr einstein
and he started bending time
he treated time like a physical object
and so now it gets very scary because
newton probably would disagree that time
is a physical object he said look we all
know what it is
it's what we measure with a clock
essentially right but here we're talking
about something else here this guy is
saying we're going to bend time
what do you mean ben time you know you
bend it like a hammock or what what do
you mean you're going to bend time
and you know you can say well bill
that's a figure of speech
it means something else in mathematics
well yeah
we got a couple problems there alone and
the first one is that 90 of the people
out there they just repeat what the
mathematicians tell them and they say oh
einstein prove that time could be warped
and they don't even know what they're
saying
because what they did is they took the
closing argument the figure of speech
and that's what they
spread out there and they said well
einstein proved and everybody every
mathematician believes that time is
warped that's what they tell you out
there now the mathematicians who know
better they say well you know we don't
really warp time this is the explanation
they go through this rigmarole where
they say okay i'm going to explain to
you what we mean by
uh time warping of time
see but that's not what they use
uh because you can't use the word warp
with time
because otherwise you're tweeting time
as a physical object so you have to go
in there and explain to them really what
you mean by time warp or whatever but
see it's that's one issue the other
issue is they're trying to give a
physical interpretation and they're
using this thingy called time which is
not a thingy
and so you can't give a physical
interpretation of causes and mechanisms
using the word time which is what the
mathematicians pretend to do or purport
to do
so they're telling you look we can tell
you how this universe works okay how
does it work well you see you have this
thing called time no it's not a thing
and we warp it but you don't warp it
well what we really mean by that is
and you say you can't do that because
all you're doing is a description of
mathematical description which you're
somehow converting in your language into
a physical object and then concluding
you know you're closing arguments uh to
the jury you're saying well we were
crying
so you took a big leap into physics
as long as you keep it in mathematics
and say look it's just a calculation
no problem it's when you bring it into
what you call mathematical physics with
flotation that's where we run into
trouble because now you turn into a
physical object you insinuate to the
masses out there who don't know any
better that you actually warp time and
when people start questioning you you
say well you took it you took it too
literally
well what was your intention of giving
me a physical interpretation using the
word time what was the purpose
okay so we have a a problem there a
serious problem because if the
mathematicians cannot give you a
physical interpretations
uh
interpretation they should stay out of
it completely they should stick with
their math their equations their
calculations and not pretend to
understand how the universe works
meaning causes and mechanisms not
descriptions
if you can explain how the universe
works physically come in in there but
don't bring time with you leave time in
your
own field game your own discipline
okay uh here we have um
quora guy and he says
uh talking about einstein he says uh
einstein realized that a watch doesn't
measure time okay
thank god for einstein instead it
measures motion
which is what aristotle said
and this guy got thousands of views and
thousands of you know thumbs up
and it turns out he's saying something
he doesn't even understand obviously
this guy never read aristotle because
aristotle already said you know what
does time measure it measures motion
and this guy gives credit to
einstein 2000 years later
yeah motion is of course the combination
of time and distance
okay how do you combine
numbers with uh
distance meaning separation if that's
what you're talking about maybe maybe
it's not this and maybe he meant
distance traveled
okay
and measure time without motion it's
impossible yeah no kidding
you need
motion to talk about time but what is
the relationship between motion and time
that's what all these people failed to
identify to discover
and you'll read out there time is what
you measure with the clock that's one of
the definitions out there they put on
and you can look up and say a clock is
what you measure with with time
so uh
what you use to measure time so so the
question is you got a circular argument
there we don't have a definition four
o'clock or for time what is a clock well
it's what you use to measure time what
is time well what is measured by a clock
great we learned a lot
yeah this these are the
definitions you'll find out there and
they're no good so we need a definition
if we're going to use a the word time
and we need to determine once we define
that word whether it belongs to physics
at all whether we have any use for it in
physics
okay so here we have
scientific definition of time what were
all these people talking about all these
years okay here it is
uh again we have that math which is
distance traveled okay and if it's in a
straight line it's the same thing as
displacement but if it's curved like
there then there's a difference between
distance traveled and displacement so
what does mathematicians do well they go
in there and they say look speed is
equal to distance divided by time okay
what they really meant is speed is equal
the distance traveled divided by time
two two dynamic concepts there okay and
then when we go to time we can just do
the little uh
you know calculation there or
put things on different sides of the
equal sign we have distance travel
divided by speed that's what time is
officially from math but what did we say
that uh distance traveled is well it's
motion and what is displacement well
it's distance separation between two
objects here we're talking about two
two motions we're saying that distance
traveled divided by speed is two motions
and so time is equal to motion divided
by another type of motion in other words
you need two motions to talk about time
okay
and of course what what's missing in all
these cases is memory you absolutely
need memory to talk about time
okay so here we have the definition
scientific definition what is time
taken from me there
qualitative time qualitative relation
established between two locations of an
object or between the trajectories of
two objects what are we measuring we're
measuring the
motion of a clock for example the hands
on a clock against the motion of the
earth around the sun that's what we're
comparing we're comparing two motions
every time we use uh the word time
whether we know it or not and what you
need here is memory because in order to
be able to do this you need to remember
uh the motions you need to remember the
starting points and the ending points
you need to uh
register them somewhere so uh that's
what time is time is simply a comparison
of two motions and you need memory for
that okay and quite a quantitative time
which is what they use in mathematics
which is a value okay is a numerical or
quant quantitative relation
establishment between two motions one of
which is a pre-established standard and
again in both cases you need memory you
can't do time without memory okay memory
is a key aspect of time so we need
memory and we need two motions
so time is not the same thing as motion
because time is a comparison of two
motions you need two motions in order to
have time if you have a single object
moving in the universe you still don't
have time because you have no reference
for that uh
object except its starting point all you
have is motion
you need two motions and memory okay
and so uh
let's go with the conclusions here so
that you can take something home with
you okay
and these are conclusions no one has
ever defined the world word time
scientifically okay
uh time is not equal to an object which
is what they say it is because they're
going to bend it they're going to warp
it they're going to they're going to use
it in that sense and 90 of the people
out there believe that it's some kind of
object because they say well we warp
time it sounds like you know you're
warping uh like warping a banana or
something you know
so you're treating it as a physical
object uh by default
and uh you can't warp or bend time right
because if you could then you are
actually talking about an object
and the mathematicians know better but
ninety percent of the people out there
who
you know
dabble in physics lightly they are not
very
keen on this issue they don't realize
that
they've been
they so they sold them some
snake oil they're telling them look we
worked time and the guy says okay the
mathematicians proved that the experts
the
scientists
it turns out they sold them a fib
okay no at least don't use that unless
you understand what warping time means
don't use that
figure of speech unless you really
understand it
and then uh from the sweet speed
equation we can deduce that time is
equal to distance traveled divided by
speed which in physics would be motion
divided by motion obviously we're not
talking about a physical object and so
time is a comparison of two motions okay
and time requires memory you can't do
time without memory
okay so
that's the take on that
let's move on to the questions that
people asked uh since last time
okay let's see what we have here
and all of them are
essentially i think all of them are
related to the scientific method so if
you've got something better to do well
then don't do it because you might learn
something stick around
here it is uh foul says
scientific definition of definition try
finding that on the internet
yeah
definition is uh
a
restriction placed on a word
usage or extent of a word
to copy and paste from google
dictionaries criminal sacrilege he says
accuse emails saying that right that
dictionaries aren't used in science they
are in religion well now let's get it
right let's get the right context there
what we're saying is that when you look
up a word in the dictionary everywhere
in the dictionary falls under object or
concept there is nothing that is
neither one of those two any any word in
there is either an object or a concept
falls under one of those two categories
there is no third category either it has
shape or it doesn't have shape hat shape
object doesn't have shape concept we're
done that's how simple it is black and
white kindergarten stuff okay and so
when we look up a word in the dictionary
and you see it as a noun
and you say well i can use nouns as a
subject of a sentence
well that's okay in ordinary speech that
doesn't translate automatically directly
into physics it's science
in sense we have to be careful and
separate objects from
concepts and when you do that you
designate us nouns only those things
which are objects those words which are
objects if the word is not an object
it's not a noun you can't use it as the
subject of a sentence officially you can
informally but not officially you can't
talk about motion you cannot talk about
orbit for example okay
no you have to say uh not the or you
have to say for example um
instead of the orbit of jupiter you
would have to say jupiter orbits
orbits is what jupiter does jupiter is
the noun okay and orbit is a verb and so
all these things that are verbs and that
are nouns in ordinary speech cannot be
taken as nouns unless they have shape
they refer to those words in the
dictionary that designate that thing
that has shape okay so that's the issue
there
and so here uh we have uh same fella i
think uh he goes in there
and he says um
gives us the scientific method according
to him he says is not a recipe for
discovering and describing new phenomena
scientific method is a logical procedure
for explaining what cause mechanism
physics or reason purpose
yeah uh so this is our answer to his
notion we're saying that um scientific
method is not it's not a recipe it's not
a series of stuffs that you have to
follow to discover something like saying
oh i'm gonna go to the basement i'm
gonna run an experiment i'm gonna
observe something i'm gonna collect some
data none of that belongs to science
science is only that last part the fact
that you know the uh
grandmother tells the little kid says
look let me explain to you a cause a
mechanism that's the part of science
okay or specifically as related to
physics so this notion that this file
has that uh
we don't follow the definition the
dictionary yeah we don't follow that
definition because in in science you
have to defend your definitions not copy
them what this file does is just copy
and paste and says oh that's science
uh no it doesn't work that way you know
the way it works in science is you have
to defend you got to get in the ring and
fight for your definitions and you can't
use authority and you can't
use
tradition and say
or democracy and say every scientist on
earth believes in this definition that's
the one i'm going to stick with
uh yeah you can stick with that but the
problem is if it's an irrational
definition
then you will not have a uh a good time
you know defending it okay
you have to have definitions that you
can defend and that you understand and
defend not just say i'm doing it because
i copied it from the dictionary okay so
yeah that's the point i'm trying to make
here
okay another fellow says
uh oh no this is this is my
proposal
for a scientific method what is it it's
a way of explaining a mechanism as it
relates to physics right uh you need
what is it you have a hypothesis which
are the assumptions and
the assumptions are the objects that
you're going to use to
simulate your theory your explanation
your mechanism the definitions that
you're going to use and the initial
scene that's your starting point once
people understand that they can follow
up they can follow your theory now they
your they can follow your explanation
and now you move on to uh mechanisms and
causes and then you end up you know with
your conclusions interpretations and
coral areas that you might have your
interpretation of what uh you got out of
it okay and uh someone said something
along those lines i think i'm gonna get
to it later but here is uh one file says
[Music]
give me a second here
says rational science starts with
philosophy
okay
philosophy philosophy is another branch
of science so there are two parallel
sciences philosophy has nothing to do
with physics physics doesn't have
anything to do with philosophy they're
both part of rational science yeah we
call it rational science we can
get rid of the rational not because it's
irrational but because it's it's the
genuine science what we have today is
again a process that has nothing to do
with science they say observe something
okay so you observe you gawked and what
did you learn you collected data you
still haven't learned anything you ran
an experiment you still haven't learned
anything
okay so the fact that you do experiments
and predictions and all this stuff
doesn't mean you learned anything that
you can explain the mechanism so that's
why that's the what we have today is
unscientific it's been running for 400
years now now we have a new paradigm
paradigm shift a new version and that's
that the one i just uh showed where you
have all these steps to explain a theory
a mechanism to someone else okay and so
now it doesn't start with philosophy and
this file continues says sense is a
collection of facts
well fact is uh what like truth uh so um
what is the fact to you is is a lie to
your neighbor you know uh maybe god is a
fact to you
yeah so you take it for granted and your
neighbor he might be an atheist and you
say well you know i don't believe in
your fact
okay so
we got to distinguish fact from fiction
this fellow living in fiction okay
derived from certain philosophical
viewpoints and observations now and in
science we do not observe anything okay
if the philosophy is skewed then the
facts are a little better yeah again no
facts or philosophy has anything to do
with physics never mind with bill or
einstein or some other scientists say
they don't know what is there
of course we don't
we don't know
in science we don't believe in science
okay in science we make an assumption
about what is there why do we have to
make an assumption i'll tell you why
because you cannot see or touch the
mediators of gravity of uh magnetism of
light we cannot see or touch these
things whatever's there
you know uh between two atoms we cannot
see what happens between two atoms
because we cannot see the mediators
and hopefully there are mediators in
there
otherwise you're introducing black magic
you're introducing god's magic you're
saying god said so
you know the earth moves around the sun
why well because angels are putting it
pushing it i don't see them
well
of course you can't see them
but that's my theory that the angels are
pushing the earth around the sun
so what have we learned you know but
that's why we have to make assumptions
to understand what the guy has in his
mind and one guy might say angels okay
so you say the angels push the earth
around the sun okay uh i have trouble
with that but okay that's your version
of how the universe works i say it's
ropes the other guy might say particles
another guy might say waves
so each one makes assumptions
uh but the angels are at least a little
more rational than same particles
especially if they're zero dimensional
particles and certainly much more
rational than waves because waves are
just
magnitude and direction waves are
concept you can't say waves like gravity
waves move the earth around the sun it's
irrational it's irrational because
you don't have an object yet first thing
you need is an object to do physics
paul says they can only know how or what
they think yeah that's the point that's
the point of physics the point of
science what you do you make an
assumption and based on that assumption
you tell a theory you you give a
mechanism that's what science is about
what physics specific is about okay
so here we see it okay um
answer to the spell
there are no facts among humans okay uh
everybody has their own facts okay
and uh we don't start again we don't
start with uh facts we start with
assumptions even if you film the rock
breaking the window defense council
would argue that the movie had was
staged in hollywood so even if you bring
a movie of a murder you can't say well
that's how it happened because you don't
know if that was staged that's the first
thing they're gonna criticize we have no
way of reproducing what mother did in
the past okay only mother nature knows
about that she's got in her final
cabinet all we can do is guess okay
and so yeah in science we start with
assumptions a statement of the facts you
have your set of facts i have my state
of facts you make your statement of what
you think are the facts i make a
statement of what i think are the facts
we ask the jurors to assume that the
initial scene is true that what actually
happened is true
it's an assumption
so we say to the jury we say this is
what happened no that's not the way we
do it we say let us assume that this is
what happened
okay because you're going to base your
theory on that you're going to find out
who the murderer is for example in order
to do that you have to first prepare the
jury with your set of assumptions
we don't begin our presentation by
stating it is a fact that world trade
center 7 was brought down by controlled
demolition
now we start by laying the foundations
to our theory let us assume that george
and company rigged wtc7
okay so you make an assumption
and based on that that's what you
tell how you tell the theory to the jury
so they can understand your theory
whether they believe your version or not
that's good they're going to figure that
out in the jury room right
now people can follow the theory that is
founded upon those assumptions you first
have to tell your the audience your
version of how things happened okay so
it's got nothing to do with facts you
don't turn your
uh assumptions into facts not in science
we weren't there at the crime scene we
can't reconstruct the actual event again
only mother nature knows the facts a
theorist merely attempts to read her
mind
okay so i hope uh that gives you an idea
of how science really
should operate if it doesn't already
okay
okay uh
and uh here we have another all these
related to scientific method this time
around a lot of people were into that
apparently got him to thinking okay
okay a fellow says
how about practically practicality
though don't you need math equations to
make a spaceship
did
thomas alva edison need math
to figure out what filament to use for
his light bulb
and the answer is no
in fact uh
tesla criticized them tesla eventually
became an enemy of edison he worked for
westinghouse
and uh
he criticized uh
edison he said look if thomas alva
edison had to
find a needle in the haystack he would
go in there straw by straw until he
found a needle
and he said he could have saved a lot of
time just by doing some calculations
that was
tesla's criticism of edison so no edison
did not use math to figure out
how to build up a light bulb which was
later on modified anyways but uh so no
you do not necessarily need math to do
technology
not in every case and in some cases yeah
you need to like in the field that i
worked in the semiconductors yeah they
they have to make the chips smaller and
so they need to calculate what sizes
these chips have to be what relations
there are they have to look at
temperature if it overheats etc there's
a lot of things involved in
manufacturing or designing really a chip
so yeah
math is used in design of chips among
other fields right uh nuclear weapons
you need a little bit of you need to
know the relations the ratios etc okay
so you do math you use that math in
there but that's not science
that's technology what you're talking
about is technology how to make
something
and in some cases you might need some
math in other cases you don't need math
at all like you know again to make the
light bulb they didn't use math at all
so no
not always do you need math to do
technology
and technology and science are two
different things technology we develop
by trial and error primarily how do you
think they come up with the values for
chips
like temperature and so on
well
they already have a running idea because
they run experiments and they look at
the experiments they learn from those
experiments that oh we heat it too much
this is what happens if we cool it too
much this is what happens there
and so based on that they start zeroing
in on distances temperature and all the
parameters that they're going to need to
make a chip
and then yes once they have that those
values now they can apply them
apply some math and say well then this
is how big we need to make the chip or
this line this bus line or whatever they
design it based on those results always
technology here we're not talking about
science at all we're not talking about
explaining how
electricity works within a chip okay
we're just talking about how to build a
chip
okay for example
and so right there you might need some
math but where did they get the math
they got it from doing experiments
measuring
coming up with equations now they have
the equation now they work off of the
equation they may not need to do the
experiment again
and just in case at the end of the whole
show i know this because i worked in the
industry quite a bit what they do once
you have a finished product they go and
test it again just in case because even
with all their calculations
uh the thing might fail because
production does not always match
mathematics
okay so this is the way it really works
in the real world
okay fellas shouldn't it be a
requirement in science that rational
theory eventually be somehow related
back to the personal subjective
experience of the scientists
to be meaningful a scientist must be
included in his own model of reality
with the objective processes of the
universe eventually resulting in the
subjective experiences he has
okay
his opinion his take on that he ends he
says this would be the interpretations
part of the third and final step in the
rational scientific method yeah and
that's where we put it we're saying that
uh you have an interpretation as a
as a scientist you're gonna a physicist
you're gonna give a
presentation you're gonna explain
something to
the crowd there right so what you go in
there and you say look this is my
interpretation this is what i got out of
it and so
nothing wrong with giving
interpretations nothing wrong with
giving closing arguments you can even
use poetry you can say
uh
gravity warps time as a closing argument
okay let's keep that in mind as a
closing argument you can use uh poetry
figures of speech whatever you want
uh maybe we make a joke no problem but
you're the core of your explanation had
better be for real you can't use the
figure of speech in the main body when
you're trying to explain something that
has to be literal
so you can't say that uh gravity warps
time in your
main uh
explanation
in your theory that's okay as a closing
argument and nothing wrong that's your
physical interpretation fine but then
you go to the
meat of your theory and what did you say
you said that
space is a physical object time is a
physical object you put them together
you created a physical object
unimaginable physical object called
space space-time and now you're gonna
warp it and explain with that why the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
all bunk all nonsense poppycock
okay that's simple you can't use that in
your theory
and so what they do they say well here's
the theory the theory is all this math
well that's a description you still
haven't told me the theory
the theory is a physical interpretation
the mechanism that you have for why the
earth doesn't flow out of the
fly out of the solar system what is
holding the earth faithful to the sun
that's the theory that you gotta explain
what are you gonna use you can't use
warped space time because where space
time is first a mathematical description
is the second space in time and space
time both
are not they're not physical objects so
you can't use them
to give your physical interpretation
that's where the whole thing collapses
and that's when they send you to the
other side of campus and say well we
don't do that here that's philosophy you
go to the philosophers and they send you
back to the these guys they say uh well
we take our cues from the mathematical
physicists
so you get to run around
okay and final issue file says talking
about neil tyson
a mathematician turned entertainer
because he doesn't do any
physics he's just making money and
presenting stuff you know supposedly
presenting it as in lieu of science
or uh
you know
giving the notion that
semblance of science right that's what
he does
some of the bitter arguments about
medicine and science during the covet 19
pandemic can be blamed on a fundamental
misunderstanding of science oh good
finally clarified that science is a
means of querying nature
and when we have enough what experiments
and enough what observations only then
can we say this is how nature behaves
yeah but that how nature behaves has to
do with description that he's talking
about if you do observe and you do
experiments so far you haven't explained
how
mechanism
causes
nature behaves all you
have told us is what you observe all you
did was just gawk and say yeah the ball
fell down okay so the ball fell down
what caused it
to fall down that's what you got to
explain but to say that describe you
know mathematically or otherwise that
the ball fell down oh yeah
i i can do that all by myself i don't
need you
no no but we gave you a a number of how
fast it fell down you know so far you
gave me a description you still haven't
told me why what caused it the mechanism
what caused it to fall down
and so this is where neil
and all his buddies fail us they feel us
they don't have mechanisms
with that i'll see you next time
we'll see